well edc is getting underway at the las
vegas motor speedway the first
performance about to start in about an
hour victoria saha is joining us live
from the speedway and victoria festival
goers can now stay and play there
yeah there's so many people camping out
here there are tents to rent even a spot
for rvs thousands of people are expected
to be here at the speedway speedway for
the three-day event
lines of cars pulling into the
campgrounds a glimpse of just how busy
this weekend will be at edc over the
next three days 400 artists will be
taking the stage fans i spoke with are
ready to rave we've been here since last
night
kind of hectic with pulling everything
in but all in all it's pretty worth it
yeah for sure love the vibes love the
energy everybody brings it out with
fellow campers so sick it was supposed
to be a big group for us and then once
the event keeps on cancelling back in
2020 and 2021 a lot of our
friends were not able to go on those
dates
but for this time i was only one stan
one man standing and these festival
goers are prepared to spend a lot of
money some even saying the campground
cost them thousand dollars for three
days
when i checked earlier today i did not
see any tickets available i also checked
the shuttles provided by edc those are
sold out as well you are encouraged to
take a taxi or a rideshare the festival
grounds here open at five o'clock
reporting by the speedway victoria saha
live local now